everyone so today I am really excited
because we're gonna be doing a bit of an
experiment since I specialized on
historical plucked instruments like this
the rather large the orb oh I thought it
was about time that I tried out some
historical strings up until now I've
mainly used synthetic string materials
like nylon carbon fiber and nail gut but
today we're gonna string up this 14
course the or bow with all real gut and
then we'll do an A and B sound
comparison to see how it affects the
sound
[Music]
so gut is a type of string which is made
from a natural fiber found in the walls
of animal intestines and string
manufacturers tend to use sheep or goat
intestines sometimes you hear it
referred to as catgut but don't worry it
doesn't come from cats the term cat gut
probably comes from the term cattle guts
because sometimes string makers used the
intestines from cows horses or donkeys
for most of history gut was the most
common type of string material for
guitars lutes harps violins violas
cellos and more so now we can understand
that famous line from Shakespeare's much
ado about nothing the character benedict
hears some musicians playing and he says
is it not strange that sheeps cuts could
hail Souls out of men's bodies
it's important to realize that gut
strings were common until surprisingly
recently it was until the early 20th
century that steel strings and guitars
became popular and that was partially
just because they were trying to compete
with banjos and mandolins meanwhile
nylon which is the most common type of
string material used for classical
guitar it wasn't invented until the
1940s okay we are all strung up with
guts and in tune and I have to admit
that I finally get that joke about
lewdness spending half their life tuning
and the rest playing out of tune it took
me quite a while but we are all strung
up and ready to go so let's do our first
sound comparison we're going to start
with a simple chord progression which is
a famous ground from the Baroque period
called la folia
[Music]
now let's hear the difference in the
context of a piece this is a really nice
Chaconne by D visa
[Music]
so my first reaction is that I'm totally
blown away by these strings I think I
didn't expect to like them so much
there's a warmth and resonance to the
gut strings that synthetic strings in my
opinion just don't have especially when
you play close to the bridge the gut
strings still are resonant whereas the
synthetic strings can just sound sort of
plasticky another big difference I'm
noticing is that the long bass strings
don't sustain as long they they're
wonderfully loud and resonant but the
decay is quicker which actually I prefer
because in solo music often you're
playing scaler bass notes and if they
sustain for too long they overlap and it
can get a bit muddy
[Music]
so I'm just having so much fun getting
used to these and hearing how they
change the quality of this instrument
which I know so well they're still quite
new but I'm already kind of sensing some
serious pros and cons in terms of the
pros I think they just sound much better
there's this warmth and resonance that I
think you can't get with synthetic
strings another one is that they're
historical and there's something really
cool about knowing that I'm playing on
the authentic strings that someone 400
years ago would have used and lastly I
love that there's less sustain so that
in general I can work less and it sounds
cleaner actually in terms of the cons
the first thing is that these are
actually really expensive just this low
bass string was like $40 and so it's a
bit of an investment also because their
gut strings they react more harshly to
humidity changes in the air which means
you just have to accept that you'll tune
more often and lastly I don't know this
from first-hand experience yet because
these are new but I know for my
colleagues that especially with these
higher strings here they go false over
time and so you might have to change
your strings more often okay so there we
have it I think I'm officially a gut
string convert and I'm gonna have fun
restringing my other instruments and
guts including I think I'll even try out
my classical guitar and see what that's
like I'd love to hear from all of you to
find out what you prefered God's
synthetic strings did you even hear a
difference let me know in the comments
so thanks so much for watching I hope
you found this experiment to be as
enlightening as I did and I hope you
subscribe and please do check out my
patreon if you
to help me make more videos just like
this one see ya
[Music]